hello everyone welcome to this session
of blockchain wallet my name is Sarah
and I am part of the simple own team
so let's get started and let's see
what's in store for us today so what's
in it for you today we are gonna
understand why do we need blockchain
wallet what is a blockchain wallet how
do these wallet work what are the
different types of blockchain wallets
they're comparisons and demo on the
usage of these blockchain wallets and we
will try to do certain transactions
using these wallets now before these
blocking wallets came into existence
what were the means in order for us to
do the transactions and what were the
drawbacks in the old days the
transactions with whatever medium and
channels we had the problems were that
the transactions were slow and banks
were the central point of failure
basically any transaction which has to
go through has to go through some
intermediary channels and has to pass
through certain intermediaries like Bank
which makes them a single point of
failure also there are issues in keeping
track of all accounts and balances data
get jeopardized manipulated or even get
corrupted across multiple systems where
the accounts and balances are maintained
now here comes into existence what is
called as blockchain wallet now what is
blocked in wallet a blockchain wallet is
a crypto currency wallet that allows
users to manage different kind of
cryptocurrencies for example Bitcoin
aetherium etc now a blockchain all it
helps exchanging of fonts easily
transactions are secured as they are
cryptographically signed the wallet is
accessible from web or mobile devices
and the privacy and identity of the user
is maintained so therefore a blockchain
wallet provides all the features which
are necessary for a safe and secure
transfer and exchange of funds between
different parties a blocking wallet is a
typical cryptocurrency wallet that
allows users to manage tiptoe currencies
it is very similar to the process of
sending or receiving money through
PayPal or any other gateway which you
use today but now you can
use cryptocurrency instead similar to
PayPal which you're using for making
transactions with your fiat currency now
let's take a look at the ecosystem of
blockchain wallets here are certain
examples like electrum blockchain dot
info jax mycelium samurai and bitcoin
paper wallet these are just to name a
few blockchain wallets which are
existing in the market but there are
many more based on the requirement you
have based on the security you require
and based on the kind of wallet which
suffices you need so we will see what
are the categorizations of these kind of
wallets are now how do blockchain
wallets work let's take a look so before
we move on to how blockchain wallets
work let's understand what a private and
a public key is and how are these keys
related to a blockchain wallet now
whenever you create a blockchain wallet
you are also provided a private and a
public key which is associated with your
wallet now let's take an example in
order to understand this imagine a
person knowing your email address is
sending you an email so in our regular
day-to-day activity if we want to
receive an email from someone we give
him or her our email ID and expect an
email from them now whatever an unknown
person is able to send emails through my
account so I am giving my email address
for receiving email but when I am
disclosing my email ID I'm not assuming
that someone will be able to send emails
through my account because then for that
he has to be aware of my email account
password so knowing your email address
will not give a person the ability to
send an email from your account you are
not giving your password to the person
to send an email you are just giving the
email address to send an email from a
particular email address an individual
has to be aware of the password
associated with it now block thin wallet
follows a similar process using public
key and private key both together public
key is similar to your email address so
basically whenever your wallet is
generated a public key is generated you
can share the
public-key with anyone in order to
receive funds private key is top secret
it's similar to your password it should
not get hacked or you should not
disclose it to anyone and you use this
private key to spend your funds so now
instead of sending an email imagine you
want to transfer money to your friend
this transfer process is done through
your blockchain wallet with blockchain
wallets you can now send and receive
cryptocurrencies as I said a blockchain
wallet has two piece public key and a
private key public key is shared with
everyone it's like an email address
private key is like your password which
should be kept secret with the sender so
with blocks in wallet no one will be
able to send crypto points just like
emails through your public key until
they know your private key but if
someone gets access to your private key
there is a high possibility that your
account is tagged and you might end up
losing all the cryptocurrency deposits
in your account now let's take a look
what are the typical features of a
blockchain wallet it's easy to use it's
just like any other software or a wallet
which you use for your day-to-day
transactions it is highly secured it is
just a matter of you securing your
private key and it allows instant
transactions across geographies
barrier-free
without intermediaries and also these
transactions charges you low-cost fee
and these wallets help you do
transactions across multiple
cryptocurrencies
so you can make payments across crypto
currencies which helps you do easy
currency conversions now let's talk
about what are the different type of
block chain wallets now basically there
are two types of blockchain wallets
based on the private keys one is hot
wallet and another is the cold wallet
hot wallets are like normal wallets
which we carry for day-to-day
transactions and these wallets are user
friendly cold wallets cold wallets are
similar to a void where crypto
currencies are stored with a high level
of security now let's take a look at the
differences hot wallets are online
wallets through which crypto currencies
can be transferred quickly they are
available
line on internet example coinbase
dachshund dot info cold wallets they are
digital offline wallets where the
transactions are signed or flying and
then later disclosed online so they are
not maintained on the cloud on the
internet they are maintained offline to
have high security and they examples of
cold wallet our treasure and ledger now
in case of hot wallets private keys are
stored in the cloud for faster transfer
in case of cool wallets private keys are
stored in a separate hardware which are
disconnected from the internet or the
cloud or are stored in a paper-based
document hot wallet they're easy to
access available online 24/7 it can be
accessed to desktop or mobile but has a
risk of unrecoverable theft when hack
cold wallets this method of transaction
helps in protecting the wallet from
unauthorized access from hacking and
other online vulnerabilities now the
wallet can be further distinguished on
these criterias there can be software
wallets they can be Hardware wallets
which are like kind of USB driven and
you plug into your USB Drive and your
hardwood wallet can be used or they are
a typical paper-based wallet where you
print your public key and a private key
on a paper and keep it in a secure place
let's talk about software wallet a
software wallet is an application that
is downloaded on a device either it
could be a desktop or a mobile or it
could be a web-based wallet which can be
accessed online now here are certain
example bags bread wallet and copay are
the popular software once so for fare
validity can be further categorized into
desktop wallet online or we can call it
web wallets or mobile wallets
now desktop wallet are like cold wallets
in which the private keys are stored in
old servers basically the desktop
wallets if the private keys are stored
in your desktop you can unplug it from
the internet do some offline
transactions and then bring it back
online now in case the main river is
lost then a cold server basically your
desktop is used as a backup server these
wallets can be downloaded on any
computer but can only
excess from the system they are
installed on so you make sure the
desktop or the machine on which you are
downloaded the desktop wallet is safe
has a backup you're maintaining the
hardware you're not letting the machine
go anywhere and it is on a secure
location
now these wallets are definitely cost
efficient and one of the examples is
electrum and is one of the most popular
desktop wallet online wallets are the
other kind of hot wallets that run on
the cloud that are available on the
Internet
now here users have the benefit of
accessing these wallets across any
device it could be tablet desktop or you
can use it from your mobile browser the
private keys are stored online and are
managed by a third party you have to be
dependent on a third party service so
for example green address is a Bitcoin
wallet which is available on the web has
an Android app it's available on a
desktop and also is available on iOS
Apple mobile wallets mobile wallets are
like similar to online wallets except
that they are built only for mobile
phone uses and accessibility these
wallets are also user friendly and they
have a user-friendly interface form
which helps you in doing transactions
easily the example is mycelium which is
the best available mobile wallet
hardware vonage hardware wallet is a
type of cold storage device typically
like a USB which stores the users
private key in a protected hardware
device these wallets are similar to
portable devices that can be connected
to the computer can be plugged in as I
said earlier it is less prone to malware
attacks malicious attacks and it is
haqq/truth
examples are nano ledger tracer and key
key at the top hardware wallets
available in the market to make a
transaction from your hardware wallet
you have to ensure the hardware wallet
is plugged into your computer system
before you can do a transaction from
your hardware wallet paper wallet a
paper wallet is an offline process for
storing cryptocurrencies this wallet is
a printed paper consisting of both your
private key and a public key which are
accessed using a QR code
since is what it says they are widely
used for storing large amount of
cryptocurrencies now in Temple our
Bitcoin paper wallet and my little
wallet are one of the widely used paper
wallets but the question arises how do I
add cryptocurrency in my paper wallet in
order to make a transaction with your
paper wallet paper wallet works with
your software wallets the online wallets
to transfer funds from your software
wallet to the public address shown on
your paper wallet so basically first you
park your funds in a software wallet
then you transfer the funds from your
software wallet to the public address
printed on the paper wallet now let's do
the comparison blocked in Infoblox an
info is a cryptocurrency wallet which
supports Bitcoin and etherium it is easy
to use and has a low transaction C it
has an API is exposed you can easily use
them to order to make your own custom
wallets also legend a No
legend an O is a hardware wallet which
offers a high security to your account
it is available for Bitcoin aetherium
and litecoin users it is also possible
to maintain multiple accounts and access
them anytime Bitcoin paper wallet paper
wallet helps you to print your own
tamper resistant Bitcoin wallet it
minimizes the threat of hacking the axis
the axis of the wallet which enables a
user to exchange currencies within the
wallet it is available for Bitcoin
aetherium litecoin and many other tiptoe
currencies with jacks a user can view
his updated balance as soon as the
processing is complete now let's take a
look at certain demos for the different
kind of wallets we have talked about so
let's first take an example of paper
wallet so bit address dot o-r-g provides
you a paper wallet it uses the
client-side JavaScript in order to
generate a random hash for your wallet
so you keep moving your mouse and it
will generate a hash public and private
key it is recommended that when you are
doing this process you should be
disconnected from the internet and once
these keys are generated you can print
it and keep it secure
tear the cachet of the browser so as you
can see on the screen this is my public
key for receiving my bitcoins and this
is the private key for me to spend it I
can print it and keep it handy with me
but of course the safety of these
physical documents cannot be entirely
guaranteed if a hacker discovers the
location of your paper wallet and
physically steals it then they can
access your Bitcoin holdings so
basically it is of high importance that
you keep the paper wallet in a very very
secure location some users hide or
disguise the paper wallet it should be
protected from physical damage if the
keys fade or can no longer be scanned
then the user will never again be able
to access the Bitcoin which are parked
in that address also take care if you
are using an incorrect type of printer
that also may damage the paper wallet
now let's take a look for our second
example of online wallet here we are
taking an example of bitpay
so you can download bitpay online and
create your account over here you can
create a personal wallet you can create
a shared wallet or a joint share wallet
once you create a wallet like if you see
the example over here this is my
personal wallet and I have three point
six four five test bitcoins over here
now in order to receive test bitcoins in
my account you can receive these test
bitcoins from test net dot point for set
dot e use - in now in order to receive
it you just need to copy your Bitcoin
address in the test net address
so the test net has given me point h7
Bitcoin so now my balance has increased
from three point five to three point six
four and I can see this transaction see
three minutes go
I just received point eight seven two
two eight seven Bitcoin the transaction
is still in process but in a while as
this transaction is getting mine on the
test net I will receive it now as I have
received it I can even make a
transaction and send it to someone so
from my personal account
I can send Bitcoin to someone whose
Bitcoin address I have and I have to
just paste it over here transfer to
Bitcoin wallet either I can select one
of my own wallets or I can search for
any other Bitcoin address which someone
has shared with me and I can send it to
that particular address now let's take
an example of our Hardware wallet how
does Hardware wallet works with the
online wallets so here we have meta mask
which has a feature of connecting with
Hardware wallet so once you have meta
mask installed you will see this option
of connect Hardware wallet now meta mask
has provided support for tracer so now
once you connect your Hardware wallet
the USB with your computer you can
select an account you want to view on
that particular Hardware wallet and you
can only choose one at a time and then
you can start using that particular
wallet for your decentralized apps so
basically once you have your Hardware
connected it is integrated with your
meta mask and then you can start running
your decentralized apps so that they can
start using the tokens or the currency
in the particular hardware wallet
so use your hardware account like you
would with anything impound log into the
apps and send ëthere eum's buy and store
er c20 tokens and non fungible tokens
like crypto cookies
so if you
click connect to treasure over here meta
mask will start looking out for the
connected treasure device so I hope you
all had a great learning session and
I'll meet you in my next session thank
you very much
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here